well you know there are so many options
here in Las Vegas to make your
Valentine's Day special for your sweetie
and if you're looking for something
sweet for your sweetheart a local bakery
can help fill any order big or small
Candace Charles joins us live from
Rolling in the dough with a look at the
delicious details tell us more Candace
Good morning Sherry good morning folks
you guys this is not a drink this is
actually a cake really this is something
that's set rolling and dough apart of
course for Valentine's Day you guys can
get the chocolate dipped strawberries or
if you don't have a loved one you can
get their Valentine's Valentine's Day
treats if you're not getting that vrd
and of course you can get some cupcakes
and I have the Wonder focusing it got
the Gino what Dad no glad that no we
practice this all right perfect okay
tell us about these cupcakes here yes uh
so this would be our classic vanilla
cupcakes
um so super delicious super moist and
this will be our Italian ring
buttercream made here in House made your
nails guys yes yes yes maybe with lots
of love obviously
um love to eat it
um got our pink going on for Valentine's
Day
um and then we have some cute little uh
chocolate hearts and lip for decor and
then some little sprinkles as well okay
so we're gonna give this a try here tell
me what I should do so yeah grab this
here yeah so we're gonna do this we'll
twist it a little bit more okay and then
you're really just gonna go make a cute
little Dot and just kind of start in the
middle apply a little bit oop just
kidding
okay tell me really quickly what are the
price ranges here there we go so price
ranges um will kind of start from 17 and
a half for uh plus X for a half a dozen
of these cupcakes here
um and they're actually for the
chocolate sorry uh these will start
about 21 plus tax and then we have the
charcuterie board and the fondue for two
20 to 25 classic cookies starting at
like 15 for the Dozen so this kind of
depends on what your sweet tooth or your
sweetie is looking for for some sweet
treats for Valentine's Day awesome
Christina we got you covered awesome
awesome okay I think I did pretty good
yes yes yes yes yes awesome well thank
you so much and this is how it came out
guys which is not too bad now they
opened at 11. but they already are
getting orders so if you want to get
something for your loved one or yourself
you want to try to get it today so you
can make sure you get it for tomorrow of
course we got to cover all the details
on our website 8newsnow.com for now live
from Rolling in though I'm Candace
Charles hey news now looks so so
delicious we've gotten pies there for
Thanksgiving before love that Bakery
thank you Candace good stuff making me
hungry already you guys what a cute name
too Roland and dough sugary love it I
love it